I hear so many leftists throw around
Islamophobia. That's a madeup term.
Okay? There's nothing irrational. An
irrational fear is the definition of
phobia. There's nothing irrational about
seeing Islam and its culture and its
values and its beliefs and its behaviors
and saying this is a problem.
Just imagine the people back in the day
when they would have to travel certain
distances for months or even years. What
is one thing that they would carry with
them? The Quran. Why? because they did
not have it on their mobile devices or
their gadgets. Brothers and sisters,
imagine you have a app, the Qurani app,
which not only shows you how much
rewards you get, but reminds you to read
the Quran, gives you reminders. Download
the Qurani app now and let it testify
for you on your mama that you read it
wherever you was.
Brothers and sisters and dear friends,
today we're going to be dealing with
another Islamophobe who actually
believes the word Islamophobe is
something that is made up. We're going
to find out why it's made up, why she
has so much of an issue with the word,
and let's see what this Islam for.
That's an absolute ignoramus, an
intellectual [__] is what she is. I'll
call other stuff, but I want to save
that for another day. Here's a video
where we're going to be dissecting all
of her claims and her stupidity and show
you guys how ignorant these Islamophobes
really are. So, let's get straight to
the video and show. Here's a video where
she's going on a rant. Let's see what
she has to offer us.
>> Nothing irrational about fearing a
culture that does not respect or
tolerate Western civilization. I hear so
many leftists throw around Islamophobia.
That's a madeup term. Okay? There's
nothing irrational. An irrational fear
is the definition of phobia. There's
nothing irrational about seeing Islam
and its culture and its values and its
beliefs and its behaviors and saying
this is a problem.
>> Okay. Interesting. So, basically she's
saying that um I don't know what she
means by this is like a madeup word.
It's not. It's an actual actual actual
act. It's phobia is a thing. What she's
trying to say is the following. That
our fear is not irrational. I think
that's what she's trying to say. is
trying to basically say the fear is a
rational fear. So, so it cannot be a
phobia. It's a rational fear. We have a
right to fear it. It's like somebody
fearing their killer. You can't say they
may, you know, oh, they have a killer
phobia. Of course, they are. It's
irrational fear. It's not an irrational
fear. So, we're going to say, okay, no
problem. If it's a rational fear, then
you need to rationalize it for us.
Rational theologically, objectively,
tell us why Islam
there's no such thing as Islamophobia
that Islam is opposing the western
values. And they're two opposites. And I
agree. You know people come and say to
me for example that um the vi values of
western values and Islamic values do not
align and 100% I agree with you 1
billion% because your western values are
hedonistic yes um and atrocities that
the western world has done across the
globe to innocent people massacring men
and children and we can see that today
how they justify it how they are putting
sanction on the uh international courts
for speaking against objective truths
like do not kill innocent people and
they're oh you're Hamas you're pro Hamas
so we can 100% % agree Islamic values
and the western values are two opposites
my friend Islam upholds Islam is uh
Islam is morally consistent not
strategically strategically like the
western world so let's see what she has
to say
>> I'm scared of this Islam is not just a
religion it is a lifestyle and their
main goal is to eradicate western
civilization
>> okay this woman is an absolute
ignoramist she needs to go back to
school uh what does she mean by that
let's hear that just one more time
>> I'm scared of this Islam is not just a
religion it is a lifestyle And their
main goal is to eradicate western
civilization.
>> Interesting. So our main goal as Muslims
is what I wake up in the morning, I go
to my local mosque, my imam says, "What
is the main objective of Islam?" And I
go to Islam is to eradicate the western
values. He'll say to me, "You're an
ignorant Muslim." The main uh
fundamental thing that Islam stands on
is what? That we worship God alone. That
God is one. And the most important
thing, one of those, the most important
thing is what? Justice. Living by
justice. We believe the greatest
injustice is to worship other deities.
So to come and say that we wake up and
Islam tells us or teaches us that we
need to eradicate the western world and
we all wake up is the biggest hoax. It's
the biggest lie that the farright and
ignoramuses like this woman this
intellectual [__] spews. It's lies.
It's not true. Don't forget to download
the Salah Pro app. Absolutely free.
Brother sisters free kiblinder ads free
salah reminders encourages to pray
salah. You can book a salah instructor.
Order a guided prayer mat. Find your
local salah hubs. Watch videos on how to
pray. It's all there for free,
inshallah.
>> And Democrats are letting it happen all
over the planet. Look at the UK for
example. In the year 2000 in England and
Wales, 7,000 reported grapes. In the
year 2024, 71,000. And those are just
the ones that are reported. What changed
in that time? Oh, I wonder.
>> Okay. Interesting. So basically she's
saying that in the year 2000 to the year
2024 something like that whatever is the
matter the rapes went from 7,000 to
71,000 and she's saying I wonder what
change okay what change give us evidence
come we made an assertion yeah it's it's
like look just because there is
correlation you're equating to causation
yes just because for example the number
of uh individuals getting raped went
from 7,000 to 71,000 you're saying ah
the cause is what there can be variet
iety of causes for that. Okay. Number
one, you know, pornography,
dehumanization of women, sexualization
of women, objectification of women.
There is so many elements that go hand
in hand. Like for example, there was a
study of 97 or 93% of British women have
been sexually harassed one way or
another. Were they all done by
immigrants? And by the way, how are you
equating immigration to Islam? Because
if you look at the top four, five
countries uh who are immigrating to uh
the UK, number one is India. So when we
look at Oxford University the study that
they've done it says these are the top
immigration to the UK India Poland
Pakistan Romania and Ireland
20% out of that 100% is a Muslim
country. Yes. Okay. The remaining 80%
are from Christian or Hindu or Western
liberal valued countries. So your
argument of that going up would equate
the following that number one it's not
Islam because at the end of the day if
you look at the statistics that you said
7,000 to 71,000 which we need to even
check India yes predominately is a Hindu
nation Poland is a Christian nation
Romania is a Christian nation Ireland is
a Christian nation so then to your
argument it's actually Christians
or/Hindus who are disproportionately
committing these crimes cuz then again
look I'll be falling into the same
fallacy as you which is correlation does
not mean causation. I'm not going to go
and blame those kind of people. What
numbers of figures do you have to come
and assert that that is due to um Islam?
And how are you equating immigration to
Islam? Meaning meaning all immigrants
are are Muslim. No, they're not. Which I
just clearly showed you. That
>> is an 800% increase and y'all don't see
that as a problem. Women are scared to
walk the streets of the UK right now and
you won't listen to them.
>> Yeah, you're right. Because majority of
those culprits who are sexually
harassing women are white. Yes. Cuz the
majority of the population of the UK are
white. the white men, you know, the
white population, the Caucasians. So
therefore, to your argument as well, all
of these women, 93 the 90%
region have been sexually harassed one
way or another. Yes. Which civilization
is it the Islamic civilization or the
Western civilization that sexually
objectifies women, degrades women and
makes them just a sexual object? Who
does that? Does Islam do that or does
the western world do that? The western
world do that. So if there's anyone
anyone's um values who are making women
to be degraded, it's the Western world.
>> When they talk about it, you call them
racist. It's the truth. They're afraid
because these men do not respect women.
It's in their culture. Islam doesn't
even see rape as a crime.
>> Okay. Interesting. So Islam does not
even see rape as a crime. Okay. Let's
let's I'm sure she she knows what she's
talking about most certainly. Let's see
what she has to say. Let's see what
evidence she's going to bring to us. And
to be prosecuted for rape in this
culture, you have to have two men
witnesses that will testify that it
happened.
>> I don't know what this woman is talking
about. I don't even know what she's
drinking. She It looks like she just
woke up in the morning. I think she woke
up on the wrong side of the bed. She's
just spewing absolute bull crap. Yes. In
Islam, when it comes to financial
affairs and financial matters and
certain elements of, for example, if
there murder or something like that
happened, a serious crime
when I say serious crime is two male
witnesses. Yes. Okay. Or one male
witness and two female. Because we
believe that a woman usually she's a
homemaker. Okay. So when it comes to
affairs of finances and working etc
that's not her areas of expertise. In
certain different circumstances woman's
testimony on her own is fairly
sufficient and enough because of the
area that she deals with like when it
comes to uh um wetness. Okay. There was
a situation a hadith of a wetness where
the woman the wetness was the one
actually who decided there was a
specific matter that happened at the
time of the prophet Muhammad peace be
upon him. That wetness that woman's
testimony was enough. The prophet
married peace be upon him's wife Aisha
was someone who would be teaching you
know so there was no like oh her
testimony cuz in a chain of narration
hadith a woman is in that chain so
subhan allah she's sh absolutely no
sense so I don't know where she got that
from and actually you need not you need
four witnesses cuz Islam deals heavily
when it comes to slander so but let's
carry on let's see what she had to say
about that there is no punishment for
raping a woman interesting she I'm sure
she's going to bring out some evidence
>> otherwise the woman gets punished
>> sorry otherwise the woman gets punished
nowhere in Islam. That's so funny. You
know, actually it's actually the
opposite. No one in Islam it says if you
do not bring evidences, therefore the
woman gets punished. No, the ones that
made the accusation. So those two men
who made the accusation against the
woman will get slandered. You know why?
Because there has to be four witnesses.
So if two male witnesses come forward
and say that woman done this or whatever
it is for that matter, they will get
punished. Okay? And we know in unique
instance at the time of the prophet
Muhammad peace be upon him where a man a
man caught his wife in bed having sex
with another man and he went to the
prophet Muhammad peace be upon him.
Number one did the prophet peace be upon
him tell him why did you not execute her
there and kill her there? No. He said I
saw my wife having intimacy with another
man. Guess what the prophet Muhammad
peace be upon him said? You know you
guys believe it's misogynistic. You know
did he say yes. Why did you not you know
go back and kill her? No. He said, "We
are going to lash you for slander
because you don't have four witnesses."
The man caught his wife in bed with
another man and he's the one that's
getting the punishment. And that is when
revelation came and said that they do
lean which is what that the man the wife
comes that he's accusing of. He comes
and they both take oaths by Allah free
time saying wahi the other part is a
liar. And the fourth oath is what? That
may the curse of God be upon the one
that's a liar. And guess what? That is
the only thing that saved that man from
getting lashed and his wife got
scot-free cuz there was no evidence. So,
alhamdulillah for Islam, how it deals
fairly.
>> And now America are sacrificing their
wives and daughters for diversity
credit.
>> Oh, and also talking about uh rape that
So, we're going to go to a narration
that she mentioned. She's saying that
you need two witnesses. Not really. This
is this is for when it comes to
adultery. Now, when it comes to for
example rape, which we're going to talk
about, which just want to correct uh do
a little correction there. Okay. When it
comes to rape, it's a whole different
ball game. Okay. This is from a hadith.
Abu al- Kar reported a woman went out to
pray during the time of the prophet
Muhammad peace be peace and blessings be
upon him and she was met by a man who
attacked her and raped her. She screamed
and ran away and he ran away. Then
another man passed by and she said this
man has molested me. A group of
immigrants were passing by and again she
said this man has molested me. They
caught the man. Yeah. Okay. What
happened? I thought if that's the case,
the men won't catch the other man,
whoever it is, which she's wrongly
accusing off. She'll say, "I'll let him
go. It's fine. There is no punishment."
Yeah. Okay. They caught the men whom she
thought was the attacker and brought him
to her. And she said, "Yes, this is the
one." Even though she didn't know, she
just grabbed another random innocent guy
by accident. Yeah. They brought him to
the prophet Muhammad, peace be upon him,
who was going to give judgment to what
happened to him to to be capital
punishment because in Islam is a capital
punishment. Unlike the western world,
like I said, the values don't align. In
the western world, what's happened to a
rapist? Little pat on the hand, couple
of years in prison, play some
PlayStation, read some books, enjoy
yourself, nice hot meals, mate, have a
nice comfy sleep, wake up and you can do
the same thing again. That's why I said
Islamic values and western values are
opposite because Islam deals with it
from the core. Guess what happened? The
cap the capital punishment was going to
given to the man. And what happened is
the following. The other man who
actually done the crime felt guilty and
he came by and said what? Oh messenger
of Allah, I am the one who attacked her.
because he did not want the other man to
falsely get the capital punishment. The
prophet said to her, "You can go now for
Allah has forgiven you because you
falsely accused another man. Go now."
She's forgiven. Look, she's gone. She's
got scotfree. Her testimony was enough.
Her testimony on one woman. And the
prophet said kind words to the man who
had been mis uh mistakenly arrested. The
prophet said to the man who who was the
actual attacker, "Stone him." And the
prophet said verily when he got the
capital punish because in Islam that's
what it is because he self he said
himself it was me okay otherwise it
would not been verily he has repented in
such a manner that if the people of
Medina were to repent in this way it
will be acceptable meaning in Islam even
the person that done it yes he got the
capital punishment but we do not speak
ill of him because his affairs with God
Almighty you know so there you go so as
you can see you're chatting you're
chatting nonsense man you're chatting
bull crap anything we're not going to
call it bull crap okay we are
>> and it's phobic to say that because
that's what's happening. Every single
area that has welcomed a mass migration
has been objectively destroyed in
Europe. Every single one go look for
yourselves. And instead of seeing that
and saying, "Huh, there might be a
common pattern, you just call people
racist for talking about."
>> So where did you where did you get this
objective truth? Can you give us some
objective truth that for example that
anywhere there's migration that's
happening that they have been destroyed?
I don't know what you're talking about.
And not only that, for example, again,
you was talking about Islamophobia. Yes.
What is there for you to fear about
Islam? Islam says for example they
should be women should not be sexually
objectified. You shouldn't have gambling
casinos places of gambling because it
destroys lives. People's lives are
ruined. Yes. Men or women who are
addicted spend their children's wealth
on gambling while the rich gets richer.
Not to drink alcohol. Yes. Because it
destroys life. It's the biggest poison
that's killing people. Liver disease,
heart disease because of alcohol. That's
the direct cost of it. Not even the
indirect cost of driving, drink driving
and running over a couple of people,
innocent people on the road that are
dying and thousands, millions of people
around the world are addicts. Yes.
Robbery. Yes. Capital punishment
robbery. And so many other illnesses
within society. So who would fear these
being banned? Only the people that
capitalize and get richer and richer.
Yes. Of this. So when you say
Islamophobia is not the thing, okay,
it's an irrational fear. Okay. What is
Islam bringing to the Western world that
it wants to uplift you? Do you not watch
pornography? It's more addicting than
cocaine, drugs, and it destroys people's
lives. And guess what? Those statistics
of rape and all that kind of stuff stems
from what? Pornography. You look at Ted
Bundy, a serial rapist killer. He came
across a magazine, a pornography
magazine when he was young. It all
started from there. And most serial
killers said what? They used to have an
addiction with pornography. Yes. So
again, I'm not saying correlation means
causation, but I'm saying, hold on a
second. this you know this shows that
there's some kind of concern. So the
argument is what why are you why are you
irrationally what's irrational fear what
is it the only ones that have irrational
fear of Islam okay are those who want to
capitalize of other people's demise and
Islam is saying no Islam is there to fix
all those illnesses and only people like
you who have an agenda who God knows
what the your agenda is is that you have
an issue with Islam because Islam gives
you a solution to your disease of
problems that you have. You took a
massive culture that hates women, hates
children, hates gays, hates white
people, hates America, hates Western
civilization.
>> This woman is such a I'm sorry. She's
actually stupid. Please forgive me. You
are one stupid of a woman. I mean, hates
women, hates children, hates gays, hates
white people.
The hell is she talking about, bro?
Where in Islam does say we hate women,
which we don't. Islam has given more
rights to women to you feminist women. I
don't know if you're a feminist way for
that matter were fighting and dying for
you were throwing yourself in front of
um the king's cart. Okay. Uh to get your
rights in what happened in the UK, okay?
Hates women, hates children. The
flipping are you talking about? Hates
children. If there's any regime that's
killing innocent children, it's the
Zionist regime that you probably
support. Hates gays. In Islam, we are
not told to hate gays. We hate the
action. And guess what? Christianity and
Judaism. Yes. Are these opposing Islamic
uh I mean the western values, the
Abrahamic fakes. Christianity, Islam,
and Judaism have these set of laws that
are all against Western values. So why
do you talk about that? It's not Islam
that has only these rules. Okay. And
they're talking about hating gays. No,
it doesn't. Hates white people. There
are white Muslims. There are millions of
white Muslims coming to Islam. What are
you talking about? Are you like
genuinely, are you stupid?
>> Brought them into Western civilization
said, "Hey, maybe because now that
they're on different soil, they'll
change their behavior. They'll change
their moral compass and their core
values because they move somewhere
else." No, they're bringing it with
them. And of course
>> bringing what with them? The majority of
pedophiles. Not that you mentioned that
are white middle-aged men to I mean I
mean even if you're going to go down the
route of religion being connected to
pedophilia whatever it is you have the
church. Do you know how many children
under the church have been raped and
killed children millions. Pedophilia is
a pandemic in the in the UK and USA and
Canada who are predominantly the
corporates. Why middle-aged men? This is
your problem. I don't and I find it so
bizarre. Like I find it so bold. The
irony. You dare to bring this issue like
oh we have this you know this culture.
What culture? What are you talking
about? These are the diseases that you
have that you are bringing to the
western world. Islamic world.
Pornography and alcohol and casino.
These are all your illnesses that is
coming to the Muslim world which we
don't want. So I don't know what you're
talking about.
>> Other cultures that they're the good
ones. There's nothing phobic about
saying some cultures do not blend into
the west. They don't. It's proven time
and time again and their behavior is
that proof alone. Not only that, but
again endless amount.
>> I mean if anything practicing Muslims
which like I said again you're creating
like all immigrants that come are all
Muslims. They're not. We prove that
anyway to show us how stupid you are. Um
but if anything if Muslims practicing
Muslims who come to Islam to the western
world they can do nothing but actually
come with their values actual values of
what? Not stealing. Yes. Treating women
like human beings not sexual objects.
Yes. One night stands and just use them
as you please and chuck them away. Do
not drink alcohol. Do not gamble. Yes.
Do not rob. Yes. Do not wash
pornography. So if anything it would
enrich the western value with Islamic
values if anything for that matter. And
if there's anyone that's going to come
and corrupt, it is like for example, you
look at for example another fine example
of Katar. Yes, let's talk about Katar
for example. In Qatar, women actually
felt safe once in their life that they
can go to a football, watch the football
and safely at night time return home.
Don't take my word for it. Let's read it
for oursel. When Andrea M from New York
uh uh M settled from New York to follow
team USA's uh journey at the FIFA World
Cup in Qatar, she reassured her friends
and family that she would not do
anything risky during the tournaments.
They were worried. What she had what she
heard about the Qatar printed an
alarming picture of the host country.
Okay. The US media portrayed of the
Middle East has been very different from
what I have experienced here. Andrea 29
told Aaz I think that her friends
decided against traveling to so they
were like no don't go there it's
dangerous those people hate women okay
said that said she's glad she came
simple things like taking a walk around
the city late at night that's something
I can't do back home but hold on a
second we was talking about importing
different values she said back home in
New York in America the country that you
live in liberated Muslim uh women's
rights you So she's saying that at back
home in New York she can't do that. She
has more of a chance of being killed,
beaten, raped, assaulted. Yes. Rather,
she's saying that she witnessed that in
Qatar.
Interesting, isn't it? At 10 p.m.
kickoff time for many of the group stage
matches and knockout games mean that
fans exit stadiums, use public
transport, and celebrate in fan zones uh
well past midnight. And women in groups
or on their own are watching football at
public screenings, singing and dancing
with other fans and moving around
without worrying about their safety.
According to the Numio
crime index, Doha routinely ranks the
the safest or the second safest city in
the world.
It's a predominantly Muslim country. But
I thought we hated children, women,
gays, and white people. You know for Jav
Nakuna the experience has been a stark
contrast to her home country South
Africa which ranks as among the most
dangerous countries for woman woman
travel. Is it a Muslim country? No. We
have a very high crime rate in my
country especially against women. She
said according to recent government
figures more than 1,000 women were
murdered in South Africa in three month
period between the start of July and the
end of September. The list goes on. I
think the point is made. We'll just
carry on and see what else this little
um intellectual garbage has to say. of
studies have shown that diversity
sometimes does not work because when
cultures are different so are values and
so are morals and when you try to put
two people like that under the same roof
same roof meaning citystate country it
doesn't collide it clashes and your
inability to have a difficult
conversation about that is costing women
and children their purity virginity and
their lives
>> I think she's talking about the western
western woman she's talking about the
western women who are being who are
suffering this at the hands of the
western values simple as I've brought
evidences studies
I've brought evidences bro I brought
hadith She's brought nothing but a
tangent. I think she was having maybe
maybe you know her hormones were a bit
her hormones were a bit high that day
cuz she has no idea what she's talking
about. Let me make this very casually
clear.
>> Snap out of it. There's no such thing as
Islamophobia. Islam does not belong
here. Even Islam says death to western
civilization.
>> This what a stupid Oh my I'll be honest.
I don't know how I'm reacting to this.
This is actually stupidity, bro. Even
Islam says death to the western. What
the hell are you talking about? This is
such an embarrassment for you. Such
Please tag her. I'm going to put her
name. Please tag this woman. She's the
most stupid woman I've come across in my
life. How stupid can you be? Actually,
I'm so so you are stupid. You brought no
evidence. You're just ranting, ranting,
ranting, ranting.
>> And you left us say, "Come on. Come on.
We love you. We're accepting. We're
welcoming."
It's a joke. I just hope you and your
children aren't the ones having to pay
the price like these women in England
are. That would be a damn shame.
>> The only one that's paid the price sadly
in the Western world who are being
affected by this social diseases is the
Western women at the hands of those
Western men. It's as simple as that. It
is as simple as that. Brothers and
sisters, if there's more videos of
absolute ignorances like this individual
or many of them, just bring them to me.
I just love it. I just love it, guys. I
just love intellectually eating them up.
Brothers and sisters, hope you guys
enjoy this video, inshallah. And hope
you like our new setup. Thanks to the
alhamdulillah salam team here, brothers
and sisters, where we're trying to bring
you guys amazing content. At the same
time, we would like you guys to download
our Salah Pro app, which is a for our
donors. If you want to be a donor, you
can donate yourself as well. You have
got free kibainder ads free. Salah times
encourages you to pray. Bra says it's
the only app that encourages you to pray
inshallah. You can order a guided prayer
mat, book a salah instructor, you can
find your local salah hubs where you can
learn how to pray salah, watch videos on
how to pray salah. The app is for
absolutely free. Salah pro on Android
and iOS. Download it now inshallah. Hope
you guys enjoy enjoy the video.
Okay, we better.